Now unfortunately, the basic form of the functional class pattern does result in
duplicated method, as we saw with the earlier form of the decorator pattern.
The line adding .move as a property of Car creates a brand new
function every time we invoke the Car constructor function.
Looking at the diagram again, you can see that every instance of
the Car class has its own unique version of the move method.
We may prefer instead, to have it be the case that one function object is
shared across all Car objects to save memory.
To avoid having so
many duplicate versions of the move method, we'll need to move the code that
defines the move method outside the body of the Car constructor function.
In this way, the interpreter will only visit that code one time.
And therefore, only build one such function to be shared across all
the instances.
Rather than building a new one every time we invoke a Car.
But notice, if we have moved the definition of the move method outside of
the body of the constructor, then this function should no
longer have closure scope access to the obj variable.
The obj variable's where we'll be storing the instance of the car.
So if this is off limits, the move method won't work at all.
How can we write this function such that
all the instances of Car could make use of it, even though it
won't have access to the closure scope that those instances were created in